und dann ist die große wissen sie auch
noch im krieg mit unseren kindern jeden
freitag demonstrieren weiter deutsche
schüler für mehr klimaschutz friday the
future ist das und wer kinder hat hier
im saal der weiß was es bedeutet wenn
die freiwillig das heimische wlan
verlassen von wegen und politische
generation aber muss das denn während
der schulzeit seien fragen jetzt
besorgte spießer ja klar
weil sonst keiner drüber berichtet hier
dieser junge argumentiert sehr schlüssig
was kann man lernen und lehren nicht für
die schule
[Musik]
so steht's in seinem stundenplan deutsch
mathe englisch und am nachmittag drei
stunden scheiß zukunft ja das haben wir
jetzt davon dass wir den kindern in der
schule die fakten zum klimawandel bei
gebracht haben es war ein fehler
jetzt verlangen die dass man aus den
fakten regelrechte konsequenzen zieht
also quasi konkrete politik statt
sonntagsreden deshalb begrüße ich es
sehr dass junge menschen schülerinnen
und schüler demonstrieren und uns
sozusagen mahnen schnell etwas für den
klimaschutz zu tun
gegenfrage warum muss man sich erst zu
sowas ermahnen macht das doch von
alleine
mein gott der unwürdige groko streit
über das neue klimaschutzgesetz beweist
doch dass die kinder recht haben ihre
ungeduld und das mit der schule pflicht
meine güte demonstrieren was lernen
schließen sich noch nicht aus zumindest
wenn die lehrer mit auf die dämmung
kommando
die summe der beiden paketen konate
reagiert mit den leuten ist gleich dem
quadrat der rapper den gewinn mit dir du
irgendwie auch und dringt nicht zu ende
es geht doch es geht doch mal wenn und
aber es zu lustig und gleichzeitig
bestürzend wie sich jetzt vor allem die
afd
über die hartnäckigkeit der schüler
aufregt für diskrete thunberg die
16-jährige symbolfigur oder demos
inzwischen ja ein hassobjekt eine art in
persona non grata
ja da sind bei einigen wenn es um die
geht sind bei einigen wirklich die
letzten schamgrenzen gefallen
diese geräte die hat ja aus dem schule
schwänzen eine tugend gemacht
ihr folgt eine ganze armada öko
politisch korrekter kindersoldaten was
da geschieht liebe freunde das ist
politischer kindesmissbrauch und nichts
anderes als dass wir werden die schüler
in der schule indoktriniert und
instrumentalisiert sie gehen auf die
straße sie haben noch nie eine
stromrechnung bezahlt mehr tricks von
storch die geistige energiesparlampe der
fdp mann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
kinder bezahlen keine stromrechnung
manche kinder arbeiten ja noch nicht mal
der umgang mit greta zeigt wirklich
exemplarisch die ganze arroganz der
älteren generation
greta thunberg hat eine einladung zum
weltwirtschaftsforum aber ganz ernst
nimmt man sie dort offenbar nicht was
genau möchtest du denn ändern alles
ändern ja die würden geräte am liebsten
bei ikea im small land abgeben
fakt ist wir älteren sind schlicht mehr
das ist ja diese oper calypso die am
ende vielleicht so apokalypse führt
wahrscheinlich und während manche gerade
wieder die senkung des wahlalters auf 16
fordern verfolgen andere einen ganz
neuen denkansatz
deutschland hat ein völlig neues problem
junger menschen
jahrelang hatten sie sich in ihrem
miefigen zimmer eingeschlossen und am
rechner irgendwas geguckt was wir lieber
nicht wissen wollen und jetzt sind sie
plötzlich draußen und demonstrieren für
ihre zukunft ohne uns zu fragen
diese extremistischen gut kinder was
glauben die verdi sind keine haare am
sack aber schilder hochhalten
deswegen unsere forderungen wahlrecht
erst ab 60 eine aktion der senioren
union
denn all die jugend trotz und
[Applaus]
ja
am 6
es ist ja so unsere jugendlichen sind
gerade so dermaßen anstrengend viele
politiker haben schon einen regelrechten
tinnitus wegen und die plagen
demonstrieren ja nicht nur für
klimaschutz sondern auch gegen artikel
13 der neuen urheberrechtsreform fürs
internet und zwar zu recht kann es
eventuell sein dass diese groko gar
nicht so viel ahnung hat von online und
so wir müssen erstmal wissen selber als
politiker was passiert da wir sind ja
alle auch nicht in dem internet
aufgewachsen
st aber da wo du aufgewachsen bist gab
es immer den intershop
[Applaus]
sie wissen das war damals als
deutschland noch von dieser firewall
getrennt wurde artikel 13 darf in seiner
jetzigen form auf keinen fall kommen
deswegen führen die kids ja seit wochen
ihren krieg fürs freie netz im grunde
ein emo jihad wenn sie so wollen ja die
an sich gut gemeinte idee hinter artikel
13 wer ist verfolgt hat weiß es in
zukunft sollen nicht mehr derjenige der
was hochlädt bei youtube oder anderen
plattform urheberrechtlich haften
sondern die plattform genau das könnte
aber dazu führen dass demnächst
automatisierte upload filter schon beim
hochladen alles blockieren was ihr nicht
klar zuordnen können parodien zum
beispiel oder remixe nicht im sinne der
meinungsfreiheit genau solche upload
filter hat mir übrigens union und spd im
koalitionsvertrag als unverhältnismäßig
abgelehnt aber gut da waren sie
wahrscheinlich besoffen idee warum
zahlen plattformen wie youtube die ja
ohne ende werbe kohle kassieren nicht in
so einer art ja internet
verwertungsgesellschaft ein und das geld
verteilen wir dann vielleicht sogar mal
an die kreativen die das netz mit inhalt
füllen ja ich erkläre ihnen mal mit so
genannten moment - das wort haben wir
die jungen kollegen auf geschrieben ich
bin 52 meine damen und herren das
internet der schönste platz der welt
aber dann kamen die gemeinen anwälte und
sagten man klaut nicht einfach content
ohne dafür zu bezahlen und die politiker
so ich verstehe bloß neuland egal machen
wir halt einen schlechten vorschlag um
das problem noch zu verschärfen und die
internetgemeinde direkt am flat übrigens
chuck norris wird nicht von upload
filter blockiert chuck norris blockiert
den upload filtern
und dann alle die wirklich ahnung haben
so ach du scheiße die reform 80 sinn und
ich so jetzt hab ich's kapiert was aber
auch zu weit gehört youtube ist gar kein
selbstloser kämpfer für die
meinungsfreiheit sondern schon ein
sie werden jetzt schockiert sein
kommerzieller konzern haben kommerzielle
interessen nur ein prozent der youtuber
kann von dem leben was sie da machen und
einige internetstars verbreiten so
berechtigte kritik am artikel 13 ist
nicht nur kluges roma in gold sie wollen
youtube
hallo leute die wahrheit über artikel 13
das ist der artikel zwischen artikel 12
und artikel 14
und wenn der so kommt soll oder darf man
schon mal panik riegeln ist die otto
sollen das internet abschalten
das weiß ich das hat eine youtube sowie
rebecca auch alle dachte ich mir wie
youtube das schon sagt ja darauf
aufmerksam macht ja dachte ich mir und
das muss dann sehr wichtig seien ja sehr
wichtig weil warum sollte youtube blühen
die idee von dem youtube ist doch jeder
etwas drauf und jeder nimmt sich was
folgte kommen yukon community
warum wird youtube immer so folgen so
dargestellt als wenn ich so soll der
kommerz wären so etwas mal
[Musik]
das nervt milch yahoo youtube macht im
jahr 13 milliarden umsatz ist unbestimmt
hausener brutto monatlich über teilen
die genauen daten die nicht rein das
geht keinen was an youtube hat locker
acht müssen neun prozent steuern mussten
noch wisst ihr das eigentlich was auf
euch zukommt wenn afrika 13 kommt dass
sie das tier auf youtube wird es
wahrscheinlich schon sehr bald so wie
wir es kennen nicht mehr geben und damit
meine ich auch nicht wird vielleicht
schon bald nicht mehr geben und mich
auch nicht was soll ich machen sollte
wieder bei lidl die einkaufswagen
zusammenschieben und erwarte von motto
internet abschalten
das hat's ja nichtmal hitler getraut und
er war echt böse
das habe ich einen youtube film gesehen
und deshalb alle zusammen gegen artikel
ich denk doch mal an mich unter druck
mai wird es nicht mehr geben
die welt nur noch nach dem was ja und tv
wehen bei youtube läuft dann von morgens
bis abends nur dass hier das konnte aber
durch mit internet oma da dem laptop es
runter gefallen
guten tag ich könnte ich sie für ein abo
des heute show youtube kanals begeistern
schließt gefälligst ein abo ab sofort